ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW LOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRIAN
CALDERON CORREO CERVANTES GEN
CHOI COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM
DALLY DAILY DAVIES FLORA MIKE
FONG VINCE FONG FRIEDMAN.
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY BLACKY LEE
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL. ANDERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK CORK SILVA
RAMOS RAY. THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE
DETAINED CALAVERAS VIA POUVOIR
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS OF
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
IMAM YES YEAR CON. HE MONEY
AFTER. THIS IN THE NAME OF GOD.
THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. ALMIGHTY GOD. WE HAVE
COME TO DO YOUR WILL. WE HAVE AN
ATTENTIVE TO THE NEEDS OF OUR
TIMES. WE HAVE LISTENED TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS. AND TO EACH OTHER
. IN THE SEARCH OF COMMON
PURPOSE. WE ARE GRATEFUL TO OUR
COLLEAGUES. OUR PERSONAL STAFF
AND THE STAFF OF THE STATE
ASSEMBLY FOR ALL THEIR WORK AND
THE DEDICATION. WE PRAY THAT
YOU'LL BLESS EACH OF THEM FOR
THEIR EFFORTS AND REWARD THEM
FOR THEIR GOODNESS. BY ANSWERING
THEIR PRAYERS. WE PRAY FOR OUR
FAMILIES. AND THE PEOPLE OF THE
DRESS OF THE DISTRICTS WE
REPRESENT. RENDON PEACE
PROSPERITY AND RENEWED FAITH I
MEAN. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US IN THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE FONG OUR
NEWEST ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS HE
JOINS US IN THE PLANS. THIRTY
SEVEN MEDICINE PLEASE PLACE YOUR
HAND OVER YOUR READY BEGIN. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE THE FLAG OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND
TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU SOME. YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING ON
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
ASSEMBLY SERVER SACRAMENTO
MONDAY FEBRUARYFOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TO BE CINEMATIC
ONE PM THE AUDIBLE KEVIN MULLIN
SUPPORTED FORTY SIX RIGHT MR
GALLAGHER SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE. LIVING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY SHALL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. MISTRANSLATED
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS SAY ARTURO BOARDED
DAVIES TO SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO ALLOW
SPEAKER RENDON TO HAVE GUESTS
AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MEMBERS ARE
NUMBERS HAVE INCREASED ON BEHALF
OF SPEAKER RENDON PLEASE WELCOME
OUR NEWEST COLLEAGUE FROM THE
FORTY NINTH DISTRICT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MIGHT FALL. MISTER
MICHAEL FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FARM. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND-
GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S ONLY MEMBERS
SO GOOD TO JOIN EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU FOR THIS
AUSPICIOUS DAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR VOTERS OF THE FOURTEENTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FOR THEIR
CONFIDENCE FOR US IN OUR JOURNEY
FIRST AT A SUMMIT THIS OR FORTY
NINE LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
YOU AS WE EMBRACE THE HOPES AND
ASPIRATIONS OF THE RESIDENTS IN
THE DISTRICT AND THROUGHOUT THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU SO MUCH ABOUT A SPEAKER AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MOVING ON
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
FILE ITEM ONE AB SIX SIX SIX
BURKE SILVA RIPPING PARENTS AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIXTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
SILVA AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN
THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE. MS PARKS
OVER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERSAB SIX SIX SIX IS BACK
ON ASSEMBLY CONCURRENCE AT THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION THIS BILL
WAS AUTHORED BY OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUE DAVID CHIU WE ALL KNOW
HIS INTEREST IN THIS AREA
AMENDMENTS INCORPORATE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM THE MINISTRATION
TO PER MINUTE THE NEWLY NAMED
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
AND INFORMATION. TO IMPLEMENT
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL THROUGH
A CONTRACT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES AB SIX
SIX SIX TAKES CRITICAL STEPS TO
ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE AND LACK OF
DIVERSITY WITHIN THE STATE'S
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE THAT
TREATS SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN IS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THIS WALL RING YOUR
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AS A PROUD
CO AUTHOR I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FULLERTON FOR
LEADING THIS EFFORT TO EXPAND
THE MUCH NEEDED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA
IT IS SO MUCH NEEDED ESPECIALLY
GOING INTO THE FUTURE WITH THE
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL WE CAN TAKE
AN IMPORTANT STEP TOWARD HAVING
THE MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
USE WORKFORCE BETTER PREPARED
FOR THE ALARMING INCREASES
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. I URGE
A NO VOTE. IS THERE ANY QUESTION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE-
ALL THOSE VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE DESERVE
VOTE. ALL THOSE VERY DESIRED
ABOUT. THE CLERK WILL CALL THE
ROLL AND TALLY THE VOTES. HIGHS
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONSIDERED AN.
NEXT WE'LL HAVE WE'LL TAKE UP
AMENDMENTS TO FILE. TEN SB THREE
FOUR NINE NUMBER BY
PETRIE-NORRIS. THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS HAS AMENDMENTS AT
THE DEATH TO FILE ITEM TEN SB
THREE FOUR NINE. NUMBER THE
CLERK WILL READ THE BILL WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL THREE
FORTY NINE WITH A MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
MADAM SPEAKER ADMINISTRATOR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO SP THREE FORTY
NINE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR AND
BURKE. THE AMENDMENTS ARE AT
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING AND MAKE
CHANGES TO BETTER FACILITATE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BELL BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
DR ED. THANK YOU MISTY TRAYNOR
S. IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS OR
DEBATE ON THESE ITEMS ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE SB TWO NORRIS YOU MAY CLOSE
ON THE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. WILL MOVE TO
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS WE WILL
NOW TAKE A VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
CAN TAKE A VOICE VOTE. ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL THOSE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED
THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE. MEMBERS WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE SECOND DAYS
CONSENT CALENDAR. THERE ARE
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR BEFORE WE VOTE. WE WILL
FIRST TAKE UP FILE ITEMS TWELVE
TO THIRTEEN ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ADDING CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK
WILL READ THE RESOLUTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
RELATIVE TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ASSOCIATION
AND ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIA BONTA
RELATIVE TO WEAR RED DAY AN
AMERICAN HEART MONTH. THE CLERK
WILL NOT OPEN THE ROLE TO. UP
THERE TO THE RESOLUTION. MEMBERS
THIS VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORS. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WOULD DECIDE
ABOUT. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE. THERE ARE SIXTY FOUR CO
AUTHORS. ON THIS ITEM MOVING NOW
TO VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ANY MEMBER WHICH TO REMOVE ANY
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY
NINE BY- SOME BIGGER MEDINA
RELATIVE TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ASSOCIATION. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG
. NUMBER THAT EVOKES ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
I SIXTY FOUR THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL YOU TO
VOTE. I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. THE
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEM ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY
ONE. I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO. THAT
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM PASSES. IN
THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ITEMS ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF THE FLOOR. MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR. THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MISSY I
TELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR
DESK. DON YEP. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I RISE
DRASTIC WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
GARREL HICKMAN IS A FORMER
COUNCIL MEMBER IN CALLING FROM
THE CITY OF LAKE ELSINORE. DON'T
REMEMBER HICKMAN WAS FIRST
ELECTED IN NOVEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND ONE AND SERVED THE
RESIDENTS OF LAKE ELSINORE FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS UNTIL TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. HE ALSO
SERVED AS MAYOR FROM
200-072-2000 EIGHT. HE
REPRESENTED THE CITY ON NUMEROUS
LOCAL AND REGIONAL BOARDS
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA JOINT
POWERS INSURANCE AUTHORITY. THE
RIVERSIDE TRANSIT AGENCY. IN THE
SOUTHWEST CITIES COALITION THE
NORTHWEST MISKITO AND VECTOR
CONTROL DISTRICT AND THE LAKE
ELSINORE SANYA CENTER WATER SAID
THORGY. COUNCILMEMBER HICKMAN.
ALSO TOOK AN ACTIVE ROLE IN LAKE
ELSINORE VALLEY CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE OF THE DOWNTOWN
MERCHANTS ASSOCIATION UNITED WAY
LAKE ELSINORE VALLEY EDUCATION
FOUNDATION. AND SUPPORTED HIS
WIFE IN HER ROLE WITH THE LAKE
ELSINORE WOMEN'S CLUB. HE BEGAN
HIS PUBLIC SERVICE WHEN HE WAS
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD AND ENLISTED
IN THE U. S. AIR FORCE AND
SERVED FROM NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT
TO NINETEEN SIXTY THREE. HE THEN
WENT ON TO EARN HIS MASTER'S
DEGREE IN BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION WITH AN EMPHASIS
IN FINANCE AND HAD A SUCCESSFUL
CAREER AS AN INTERNATIONAL
BUSINESSMAN. DURING HIS
RETIREMENT HE WORKED AS A
SUBSTITUTE TEACHER FOR LAKE
ELSINORE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
. COUNCIL A COUNCIL MEMBER
HICKMAN'S LEADERSHIP DEDICATION
TO PUBLIC SERVICE AND THE LOVERS
COMMUNITY ARE TRULY COMMENDABLE
AND HE HAS LEFT A LASTING LEGACY
IN THE CITY OF LAKE ELSINORE. HE
IS SURVIVED BY HIS BELOVED WIFE
OF TWENTY SIX YEARS AMY HIS SONS
TODD IN WILL AND HIS DAUGHTER IN
LAW JENNIFER TWO GRANDSONS
JULIAN AND NORA MEMBERS I THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY AND AGAIN I ASKED WE
ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF FORMER
COUNCIL MEMBER FOR THE CITY OF
LAKE ELSINORE. DARYL HICKMAN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
SEATTLE. MR WARD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER IS WITH A
HEAVY HEART THAT I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A SAN DIEGO
CIVIL RIGHTS CHAMPION MORRIS
CONSIDER. MORRIS DEDICATED HIS
LIFE WORKING ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES TO CONFRONT SOME OF THE
LOWEST ASPECTS OF HUMAN NATURE.
HE WAS BORN IN THE BRONX WAS
PASSIONATE ABOUT HISTORY AND
HUMANITY AND STUDY INTERNATIONAL
RELATIONS HERE IN A FULL RIDE
SCHOLARSHIP AND WORKED IN
INDONESIA BEFORE RETURNING TO
THE U. S. WHERE HE LEARNED OF
THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE. AND
TOOK A JOB IN A WASHINGTON
INDIANAPOLIS AND COLUMBUS OHIO
OFFICES. HIS SON'S HERE THE
STORY OF HOW IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE MORRIS ARRIVED IN SAN
DIEGO ON A FEBRUARY DAY WHERE IT
WAS SUNNY AND HAD NO SNOW. AND
SAID OKAY WE'RE NOT MOVING
ANYMORE WE'RE GOOD. WE'RE LUCKY
HE CAME TO SAN DIEGO THERE WAS
SO MUCH WORK TO DO. MORRIS
FOUNDED THE LOCAL CHAPTER OF THE
ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE AND
IMMEDIATELY BECAME THE GO TO
VOICE IN FAVOR OF TOLERANCE AND%
EQUALITY. MORE SOON WAS
APPOINTED TO THE INTEGRATION
TASK FORCE TO WORK ON ENDING
SEGREGATION IN THE SAN DIEGO
BUILT RELATIONSHIPS AND
ALLIANCES BETWEEN THE EDL AND
OTHER ETHNIC AND RELIGIOUS
COMMUNITIES. HE HAD NO TOLERANCE
FOR HATE HE NEVER SHIED FROM
REPRESENTING THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY NOREN DENOUNCING
INJUSTICE WITHIN ANY COMMUNITY
AND FUNDAMENTALLY IMPROVED
CALIFORNIA. BY EVERY MEASURE
MORRIS WAS OUTSPOKEN FULL OF
PASSION AND DEFINED BY COURAGE.
IN HIS EARLY YEARS HE ATTENDED A
KU KLUX KLAN RALLIES TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND HIS ADVERSARIES AND
WAS TARGETED EXPLICITLY BY WHITE
SUPREMACISTS FOR SPEAKING OUT
AGAINST THEIR HATEFUL RHETORIC.
AFTER TERROR STRUCK ON NINE
ELEVEN MORE STOOD UP TO HELP THE
MUSLIM COMMUNITY FOR THE STRESS
PLACED ON THEIR PLACES OF
WORSHIP. IN SAN DIEGO MORSE
REGULARLY TAUGHT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS ABOUT THE EFFECTS OF
HATE CRIMES ON VICTIMS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND ESTABLISH A
REGIONAL HATE CRIME REGISTRY TO
HELP TRACK AND ADDRESS
INCIDENTS. HE SERVED ON TASK
FORCES AND JOINT COMMITTEES
AIMED AT PREVENTING AND
RESPONDING TO ANTI SEMITISM.
MORSE'S PASSION FOR SOCIAL
JUSTICE FOR EVER CHANGING
LANDSCAPE OF SAN DIEGO AND
NEEDED A SAFER AND MORE TOLERANT
COMMUNITY FOR PEOPLE OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS. WE WILL MISS BUT WE
WILL PASS FORWARD HIS BRAVERY
HIS URGENCY AND HIS HUMOR.
MORRIS'S SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS DOREEN
SONS SIBLINGS AND ONE
GRANDDAUGHTER. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
KEEPING MORRIS CONSIDERING HIS
FAMILY IN OUR THOUGHTS AS WE
ENTER IN HIS MEMORY TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER WARD MISS
DAVIES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. IT IS WITH DEEP SADNESS
AND PROFOUND SENSE OF LOSS THAT
I GIVE THIS MENTOR HIM FOR MY
DEAR FRIEND AND MENTOR ROBERT
DOUGLAS MEANING. ROBERT WAS
TRAGICALLY KILLED ON FEBRUARY
THIRTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO IN
A PLANE CRASH IN KANSAS. ROBERT
WAS AN ORANGE COUNTY NATIVE AND
A PROMINENT COMMUNITY LEADER IN
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY. HE WILL BE
REMEMBERED AS ONE OF THE MOST
CONSEQUENTIAL RESIDENTS TO SHAPE
THE CITY OF LAGUNA GAL. ROBERT
WAS A MANAGING PARTNER QUANDARY
LAW GROUP WHICH HE FOUNDED IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN. ROBERT SERVED IN
THE LAGUNA GAL CITY COUNCIL FROM
200-062-2000 FOURTEEN AND
SERVICE MAYOR IN THE CITY OF TWO
THOUSAND NINE. AND TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN. ROBERT SERVED AS THE
FOUNDING PRESIDENT OF A. C. C.
O. C. BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND
WENT ON TO HOLD THE CHAIRMAN
POSITION. IT WAS ALSO FOUNDING
PAYER SORRY FUNDING PRESIDENT OF
THE GOING TO GET MILITARY
SUPPORT FOUNDATION AND SERVED
SIX YEARS AS CO CHAIR OF THE
MILITARY SUPPORT COMMITTEE.
ROBERTS LIFE WAS PHILLIP
PHILANTHROPY SERVICES AND SOME
OF THE CHERVIL EFFORTS INCLUDED
BOARD MEMBERS OF SOUTH. COUNTY
OUTRAGE CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD OF
STONY BROOK CHRISTIAN SCHOOL.
BOARD MEMBER OF MANAGERS OF THE
SOUTHCOAST YMCA. BOARD MEMBER OF
THE SADDLEBACK COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FOUNDATION. BOARD MEMBER OF THE
BOCHNER INSTITUTE FOR
ADVANCEMENT OF CHOIR MUSIC A
CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT HELPS FROM.
PAST PRESIDENT OF THE LAGUNA GAL
LIONS AND RECIPIENT OF THE
LAGUNA LINES A YEAR. AWARD AND
PRESIDENT GIVEN THE GOVERNOR
CLUB AND CHAIRMAN OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE OF THE GOOD IN
THE GALLUP CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND RECEIVE THEIR VOLUNTEER YOUR
OF THE WORD IN TWO THOUSAND SIX.
ROBERT EARNED A BACHELOR OF ARTS
DEGREE IN POLITICAL SCIENCE FROM
AZUSA PACIFIC UNIVERSITY WHERE
HE WAS AWARDED THE MOST
OUTSTANDING POLITICALSCIENCE
STUDENT AND LATER INDUCTED INTO
THEIR ACADEMIC HALL OF FAME. HE
THEN GRADUATED VALEDICTORIAN
FROM PEPPER DONE LAW SCHOOL.
WHEN ROBERT WAS IN GIVING BACK
TO HIS COMMUNITY HE SPENT HIS
TIME AS A Y. INDIANGUIDE THE
INDIAN PRINCES CHEAP AN AYSO
SOCCER REFEREE. A CHURCH MUSIC
DIRECTOR AN AVID RUNNER. ROBERT
LEAVES BEHIND HIS BELOVED WIFE
SUSIE AND THEIR FOUR CHILDREN
JONATHAN KATIE WESLEYAN GRANT.
GOD PUT SPECIAL INTO OUR LIVES
SOMETIMES FOR A LONG PERIOD. AND
SOMETIMES FOR JUST A MOMENT.
ANYONE THAT WAS BLESSED TO HAVE
EVEN A MOMENT WITH ROBERT WOULD
CHERISH THAT TIME FOR THE REST
OF THEIR LIVES. YOU WILL BE
DEARLY MISSED MY BROTHER IN
CHRIST IN FRONT. THANK YOU MISS
DAVIS MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE
NAMES TO THE DEATH. TO BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUESTED.
DR CHOI YOUR
RECOGNIZING YOUR DESK. THANK YOU
GENTLEMEN AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY WITH A HEAVY AND A SAD
HAWK- FRIEND AND A COLLEAGUE
ROBERT MEETING- WILL FOREVER BE
REMEMBERED AND MISSED ROBERT THE
BROUGHT THE WITH HIM- SO MUCH OF
POSITIVITY. AND DISASTER FOR
LIFE. ROBERT WAS AYE A PILLAR IN
THIS OUR COMMUNITY AND- IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY. HE WAS ALWAYS
SO EAGER TO WILL LEND A HELPING
HAND OUT TO ANYONE AND EVERYONE
IS A PASSION FOR SERVICE SO WAS
ARE AT THE CENTER OFFICE ARE
ENDEAVOR. ROBERT WAS SO AMENABLE
STRONG FAITH- IN OUR WATER OLD
AS WELL. HE RAISED HIS A
WONDERFUL FAMILY WITH A STRONG
VALUES AND I'M ALSO. ROBERT WAS
A STRONG CREATIVE AND A FISCALLY
CONSERVATIVE LEADER IS STROLLED
UP TO BE A PART OF THE SOLUTION
TO OUR LOCAL AND THE STATE
ISSUES ROBERT WAS ALSO VERY
ACTIVE IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
HAVING SERVED ON THE
REPUBLICANS. LAW STUDENT
ASSOCIATION AT THE PUMP ABOUT
NINE LAW SCHOOL WHERE HE
GRADUATED AS A VALEDICTORIAN OF
HIS CLASS AND TO CONTINUING TO
SERVE IN MANY ROLES SO THAT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IN ORANGE COUNTY. I
FIRST MET NO ROBERT WHEN I
SERVED. THE WHOLE ON THE- AND HE
SERVED ALL DAY LAW. THE GAL
COUNCIL FIRST OF A CITY
COUNCILMAN. AND THAT MESS MAYOR
I WAS A BEING ON THE- BY SILICON
AT THAT TIME. ROBLIN ARE OF THE
OWN. FOR TOGETHER AND I DIMINISH
THE FIRST HAND MISTER AFRICA THE
- I KNOW. AND AS THE AND- FOR
ALL HE DID. MY MOST DISTANCE AND
THE HOT OAKLAND. GO OUT TO HER
SO WAS. AND OF THE FORTUNE
JONATHAN A- WESLEY N. THE GRANT
MAY GOD BLESS THEM AND KEEP THEM
ALWAYS THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU
TWENTY. MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE
NAMES THE TEST BE PRINTED IN THE
TURN ALL REQUESTED YOUR IN
MEMBER WILL BE D. READ PRINTED
IN THE DRY. MOVING ON TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE FOUR ON STATE
ADMINISTRATION WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM FOUR FOR.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS. WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY THIRD CHECK IN SESSION.
THURSDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTH
FLOOR SESSION AT NINE AM. ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL E
PASSED ENTERTAINED ALMOST SHALL
BE CONTINUED. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER BUSINESS I AM READY
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
. MISTER NAZARIAN MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTH AT NINE
AM.